The first way I'm going to try to do this is to start with the coordinates of
this point. So, I have this y value, 10 minus the y value of this point, which
is 2, and I divide that by the x value of the top point minus the x value of the
lower point. Simplifying, just gives me 2. Now, let's try starting with the
coordinates from the lower point first. We'll take that y value, 2, and subtract
10, and switch the coordinates in the denominator as well. So, we have 3 minus
7. Now, instead of positive 8 over positive 4, we have negative 8 over negative
4. But in the end, this reduces to the same answer of 2. So, we can see that it
doesn't matter which points coordinates we put first, as long as we're
consistent.